one of the country's newest and youngest
chess champions is being praised for his
perseverance through incredible hardship
Tanny at alumi is just 8 years old and
only learned to play chess about a year
ago he and his family came to New York
as refugees from Nigeria in 2017
well now Tanny is competing with the
best and the brightest in his age group
with hopes of becoming a world champion
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn is here with his story of
lad good morning good morning
Tanny grew to love chess after a teacher
taught his class how to play he asked
his parents to join the school's Chess
Club and within months there was no
doubt he had a bright future in the game
tani atewa me has taken the chess world
by storm it's the thinking you have to
like understand a lot of stuff just last
week the third grader took down 73 of
the best chess players in his age group
in New York to win his division in the
state championship setting a record in
the process I was the first to win
States like my first was like my first
state to ever go to and win it his
intellect his aptitude his capacity to
learn chess is off the charts Russell
makovski is Tani's coach at his
elementary school PS 116 he says tani
quickly shot to the top of the class
from not playing until beating the rest
of us in one year is unheard of all
while living in a homeless shelter you
heard that right
tani and his family are homeless they
fled northern Nigeria in 2017 fearing
attacks by the terror group Boko Haram I
don't want to lose anyone all of my love
in walks his parents have applied for
asylum and say even without a place to
call their own they'll do anything to
support their son we are grateful to God
for giving us the opportunity to put him
in a school that you can see is go and
get his career yeah the video hyung is
Grand Master in the world and beat the
world champions record
a lofty goal for the eight-year-old
refugee but if you pause just for a
second to doubt him well he's already
called checkmate anything is possible
God is like God Cain you can do anything
for me you can do anything for my family
as we were speaking to the family an
attorney called to let them know he
would represent them in their asylum
case pro bono a go fund me page for the
family has raised more than $65,000 tani
now has his sights set on the elementary
national championship this may Nick
Kristof wrote about him in the New York
Times this weekend he said talent is
universal opportunity is not I covered
Nigeria for many years Boko Haram has
killed 20,000 people displaced 2 million
he's here in the United States can't
help but cheer for him and his family -
Thank You bud thank you